commuters in Rio de Janeiro were happy
to see bus fares back to their previous
level of two rails in 75 almost 1 euro
they had gone up to 295 el monte vista
south boy the demonstration was
effective necessary and showed results
because we are now paying the old fair
thumbs up our guy I thought you funk
that you would but this is our vows the
government shouldn't have waited for the
protests to lower their fares despite
the move to row back on the fare
increase demonstrators continued the
protest such as here on the outskirts of
Rio and the list of grievances has grown
many are upset about the billions being
spent to prepare for next year's soccer
world cup as well as widespread
corruption this is not just because of a
fare hike this is for our rights the
people woke up the bus fare hike was
just the moment of awakening now we are
fighting for better health care security
and education we're tired this is the
time to fight we've had enough of the
injustice shared you don't is your
season I want education I want good
hospitals and not a football stadium for
God's sake hundreds of thousands of
people are expected to join the protests
in some 80 cities including Rio de
Janeiro
you